مع العام الجديد ليس شرطا ان تكون جميع
البدايات جميله مؤشرات كثيره يبدو انها
ستنقل اوكرانيا وروسيا معها نحو عام دموي
اخر
ويبدو ان مسار الحرب اختار الصعود على سكه
جديده نحو مزيد من التصعيد
باستراتيجيات وخطه مختلفه تنوعت اساليبها
ومصادرها لكن الهدف واحد
دعم قوات اوكرانيا للرمق الاخير
مساعدات من كل حدب وصوب لتعزيز قدرات
القوات الاوكرانيه عسكريه ومعنويا
والاهميه
لكن جميعها رغم تحقيق مكاسبه بفضلها لم
توقف بوتن عن اصراره لاثبات ما تمسك به
منذ اليوم الاول انه اوكرانيا شرقيه وان
القلب ليس كل العالم حزمه الاسلحه الجديده
التي قدمتها واشنطن حلفائها الاكياف تقدر
باكثر من ثلاثه مليارات دولار
فالاسلحه الجديده وان دلت على شيء فعل
تغيير في نهج واشنطن وباريس و برلين لان
دعمها الاخير يشكل المحور قوه للاكرانيين
ويحبط ايه تصعيد روسي جديد
تقرير لصحيفه
اكد ان الشريحه الجديده
ستعزز من زخم كلاب ودعم القدرات الدفاعيه
للجيش الاوكراني خصوصا ان لمدرعات براد
للقتاليه ميزات النوعيه كافيه لقلب
الموازين فهي مزوده بمدفع 25 مللي
وقاذفه صواريخ مضاده للدبابات ويمكن ان
تحمل سته مقاتلين كما انها قادره ايضا على
اطلاق صواريخ جفل المضاده للدبابات والتي
استخدمها الاوكرانيون على نطاق واسع
تقرير اخر لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز يعزز فكره
توجه الحرب نحو مسار جديد بعد ان كشف ان
المساعدات الجديده تشير الى ان الحلفاء
الغربيين يستعدون لمواجهه عام دموي اخر
خصوصا مع دخول الحرب مرحله جديده بعد
هدومين اوكرانيين ناجحين دفع القوات
الروسيه من شمال شرق البلاد وجنوبها